parmi les 389 liste des communes de plus
de 1000 habitants des yvelines pour les
élections municipales de 2014 18 %
d'entre elles présentaient des femmes
comme tête de liste en 2020 29% des
listes sont représentés par une femme
elles sont 110 candidats tout au talent
un meilleur score qu'au national où 23%
des listes sont menées par des femmes
il faut savoir que les femmes reviennent
de très loin à elles ont obtenu le droit
de vote
en 1944 les premières élections
auxquelles elles ont voté sont des
élections municipales en 1945
elles ne vont pas pendant toute la
quatrième république c'est à dire
jusqu'en 1958 le ne vont pas être plus
de 3% de femmes élues et leur
pourcentage va même diminués et diminuer
encore au début de la vème république
avant de remonter petit à petit
parmi ces femmes élues qui sont déjà pas
très nombreuses eh bien nous avons
toujours moins de 1% de femmes qui sont
mères les choses changent avec la loi
première loi qu'on nomme aujourd'hui loi
parité en 2000 elle oblige à présenter
autant de femmes que d'hommes sur une
liste seulement au scrutin suivant les
femmes se sont retrouvés en fin de liste
en position non éligible
pour remédier à cela nouvelle loi en
2007 les listes doivent être composées
avec un principe d'alternance femmes
hommes si la tête de liste est un homme
le deuxième nom doit être une femme et
ainsi de suite mais nouvel obstacle un
acteur de la vie politique où siègent
peu de femmes prend de plus en plus de
compétences
l'intercommunalité si on prend chez nous
l'exemple de ce qui était le san qui est
antérieur à la communauté
d'agglomération
actuel eh bien il ya eu des mandats ou
sous moins de 50 conseillers
quand il y avait la présentation des
résultats et que les conseillers monter
sur l'estrade il y avait qu une seule
tache de couleur c'est à dire il y avait
une seule femme
ici aussi il faut une loi pour que les
femmes entrent dans l'exécutif en 2013
l'alternance femmes hommes sur les
listes doit être appliquée pour les
candidats déclarés au conseil
communautaire
aujourd'hui l'exécutif du conseil
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines comprend 45 %
de femmes donc là les choses sont plutôt
plutôt bonne pour saint quentin en
yvelines qui en gros se trouve
finalement
une des meilleures communauté
d'agglomération des yvelines et même
très très bien placé au niveau national
parmi les facteurs explicatifs de cette
difficulté d'accès au statut d'élu pour
les femmes
le réseau il ya une sorte de cooptation
des des hommes entre eux pourquoi parce
que ils ont plus de temps que les femmes
parce qu'ils s'occupent mois à la maison
et donc ils ont des réseaux que ce soit
au bistrot réunion au club dans les
partis politiques
peu importe et les femmes n'ont pas ce
temps nécessaire pour glisser d elles
mêmes des raisons ça bien de plus en
plus en particulier avec des
associations féminines et féministes les
femmes élues s'organise notamment avec
le réseau élu local avec un e a élu un
réseau dont se sont saisis des élus
yvelinoise sous l'impulsion de la
sénatrice martha de sidrac un réseau
proposant rencontre et formation à tout
et lui souhaitant promouvoir les femmes
en politique peu importe son étiquette
enfin fait qu'ils n'existaient pas pour
les dernières élections de 2014 mais qui
se présente dans quatre communes des
événements 2020 plusieurs listes qui
s'opposent et que des femmes à leur tête
comme par exemple à saint cyr l'école où
s'opposent la maire sortante sonia bros
et lady du long pont